[Music]
on this Thursday night Israel accused of
genocide in Gaza the unprecedented case
before the un's top court and the
staunch denials I'm curious that South
Africa trying to blame Israel for
defending itself remembering the man
they called honest Ed he was a fierce
advocate for social democracy Ed
broadband's indelible mark on the
federal new Democrats a close call after
being buried in a California Avalanche
so I tell myself to calm down don't
panic the man who helped her escape
uninjured and jeie Bard's second serve I
actually did better than I expected the
Canadian tennis Champs Journey To Pro
pickle
ball global national with Donna fren
reporting tonight meu
Gara good evening we begin with breaking
news in the Middle East where the US and
UK have carried out strikes on houthi
related Target tars in Yemen the White
House confirms a dozen sites are being
targeted by tomahawk missiles and
fighter jets it's in retaliation to the
largest attack on ships yet by the
iran-backed rebel group despite a final
warning from the US and allies the
houthis have been attacking cargo ships
in the Red Sea as a show of support for
Hamas and tonight South Africa is
calling for an immediate halt to Israeli
military operations in Gaza as it
formally accuses Israel of committing
genocide against Palestinians the
international court of justice has begun
two days of legal arguments the case
alleges Israel's goal to destroy Gaza
comes from the highest levels and
violates the United Nations genocide
convention no armed attack on a state
territory no matter how serious even an
attack involving atrocity crimes can
provide any justification for or defense
to breaches to the
convention Israel vehemently denies the
allegations and has taken the rare step
of sending a delegation to the un's Top
Court to defend itself a ruling could
take years but a provisional decision
might come in a matter of weeks in what
may be one of the most significant cases
ever heard in an international Court
Crystal ganing has our top
story a lineup of international judges
are starting their work hearing
arguments about Israel's attacks on Gaza
and if they amount to
genocide far from the order of the heg
please for help from a hastily erected
camp in
hunis oh God a solution we need a
solution says this woman why do they not
feel what we feel are we not human South
Africa with its history of aparti and
oppression filed the application for the
the court to hear the case in December
as a part of its argument it is using
the words of Israeli lawmakers saying
they constitute clear direct and public
incitement to genocide lies according to
Israeli government officials so I'm
furious I'm furious that South Africa
cooperates with Hamas I'm furious that
South Africa trying to blame Israel for
defending itself I hold your hand to say
thank you South Africa thank you for all
what you have been doing South Africa's
ruling African National Congress has
stood with Palestinians for
decades in court Thursday an order
instructing Israel to Halt its
operations in Gaza was requested nothing
will stop the suffering except an order
from this court without an indication of
provisional measures the atrocities will
continue with the Israeli Defense Force
indicating that it intends pursuing this
course of action for at least at least a
year outside the court dual
demonstrations grieving Israelis still
fighting for the freedom of roughly 100
people believ to be held hostage in
Gaza and pro
Palestinians the government of Canada is
not taking a position we're aware of the
filing and our government is reviewing
the case carefully Israel will get the
opportunity to State its defense before
the world on Friday Crystal ganing
Global News
London South Africa's intervention is
rare but it's not the first time a
country not involved or directly harmed
by a conflict has taken this step in
2019 The Gambia took Myanmar to the icj
accusing it of genocide against the
rohinga people both Israel and South
Africa are signatories to the UN
genocide convention which states that in
order to constitute genocide there must
be a proven intent to destroy in whole
or in part a national ethnical racial or
religious group intent however is often
the most difficult element to
prove back here in Canada former Federal
NDP leader Ed Broadbent has died born in
Ontario he served as an MP for 21 years
and led the party from 1975 to 198 89
not only did he believe in building a
good society as Eric senson reports he's
being remembered for devoting decades to
fighting for justice and equality in
Canada okay ready yeah this is it this
deal he was for years simply the most
popular Federal politician in the
country Ed Broadbent elevated the NDP to
its then strongest political showing in
history during one of Canada's most
passionate political battles confronting
prime minister Brian M roone over free
trade for the first time in the history
of this country we have a man who is
prime minister who has without even
being asked volunteer Canada as
membership and being the 51st United
States and we reject that perspective of
this country as with subsequent Party
leaders it didn't translate into enough
seats Broadband was in opposition his
entire career but Canadians admired the
often outraged new democrat who
championed the little and fought for
workers rights equal rights and human
rights prime minister Trudeau called
Broadbent a giant of Canadian politics
his service to this country was always
focused on strengthening communities on
bringing people together and believing
in uh what Canadians were capable of
former prime minister Jean cren
remembers a political foe he could still
be friends with in Parliament he was
always very civilized he was never nasty
we had tough differences but it's like
playing hockey after the game you can
have a beard together Ed was able to do
something really special he was able to
be a strong opposition leader he he
fought uh the government held them to
account but he also worked with uh
leaders Broadband grew up in oshaa
Ontario a blue collar Town his dad
worked at General Motors a time when
labor and the still new NDP were
stalwart companions he was a political
scientist and professor before jumping
into the deep end of iCal life a Social
Democrat MP and ultimately party leader
the party's purpose how we can get back
get back as a country to being both
competitive economically but also deeply
sharing and caring it was that sharing
and caring that inspired many young
progressives he was a fierce advocate
for social democracy but he still had a
genuiness and a kindness and an
authenticity that you don't often see
anymore in politics after politics he
founded the Broadband Institute that
promoted Progressive policies for a more
just Society in a statement The
Institute said our country has lost a
fierce Champion for ordinary Canadians
an intellectual who strongly believed in
building a good
Society some called Ed Broadbent the
greatest prime minister Canada never had
what Canada did have for more than 50
years was a tireless public servant a
fighter for a better country Eric senson
global News
Ottawa frigid temperatures have
officially settled in across the
Prairies with an extreme cold warning
blanketing the entire province of
Alberta a polar vortex has plunged
temperatures down to min-40 in some
areas and it's expected to get even
colder while the Deep Freeze might be
tolerable for some as Heather U West
explains it's impacting travel and some
popular winter
activities Ain one of the Calgary Zoo's
newest residents has no trouble with
this cold our beautiful bears are um
really enjoying the water today it
doesn't matter what the cold
temperatures are polar bears are going
to polar bear but for those of us
without the 1,000 PB Body and thick
white coat these extreme temperatures
pack a painful punch B's Sunshine Ski
Resort is an international tourist
destination but Thursday operations shut
down for the safety of our team members
and for the Integrity of our lift system
as well as enjoyment it's not much fun
to go out and minus 30 temperatures and
colder too cold to ski but what about
sleeping outside I'll have all my
clothes on and all my sleeping bags and
everything I can get uh get to stay warm
this weeklong camp out is raising money
for Edmonton's staller Children's
Hospital in the midst of a polar vortex
people have been especially generous
for those looking to escape airports in
Calgary and Edmonton Thursday were
posting plenty of delays even a few
cancelled flights but most planes Bound
for sunny vacation spots were able to
take off as planned pretty
happy yeah it's a good timing the Wind
sports ski hill in Calgary is closed
until the end of the week for Calgary
and Edmonton the worst of this cold snap
is still to come that happens on
Saturday morning with the wind chill
hovering around minus 50 from there the
polar vortex moves to the southeast the
skatan will have icy temperatures
through next week but BC and Alberta
should be back to normal more seasonal
temperatures by Monday methu Heather ux
West in Calgary thanks Heather we're
hearing tonight from a survivor of
yesterday's Avalanche at a California
ski resort near Lake Tahoe Janet he was
saved by a stranger after being buried
in the snow unable to breathe the
Avalanche Heaven death behind me her
husband took this video right after the
Avalanche came down at Palisades Tahoe
she says she suddenly felt the ground
slip away as she fell 60 M down the
mountain I couldn't put myself up
because I the snow was so heavy on on
top of me and uh I was buried my face
buried in the snow as she lay underneath
the snow she heard a voice above her
saying I've got you I think that's the
best thing I ever heard in my life she
snapped this picture with her rescuer
one man died in the Avalanche and
another person was injured former US
president Donald Trump lashed out at New
York's Attorney General on the 10th
final day of his civil fraud trial
Leticia James is seeking hundreds of
millions of dollars in fines which
threatens his involvement in New York's
real estate industry Trump says it's a
Witch Hunt she campaigned on I will get
Trump if you've ever seen any of the
seen any of her Clips they're horrible
Clips actually the anger she's got
serious Trump derangement
syndrome Trump also insulted the judge
seizing an opportunity to speak in court
before getting cut off as Jackson prco
reports Trump's got a lot on the
line Donald Trump came to fight for his
business Empire before a judge who has
already ruled he committed fraud you see
this is a case that should have never
been brought and I think we should be
entitled to damages it's Trump who faces
up to $370 million in civil penalties
for allegedly inflating the value of his
business assets New York's attorney
general wants him ousted from his own
company and barred from doing business
in the state she's a political hack the
Attorney General the judge is obviously
extremely friendly with the group in
court Trump launched into a five-minute
tie raade during closing arguments
telling the judge what happened here sir
is a fraud on me judge Arthur engeron
told Trump lawyers to control their
client after warning the former
president not to deliver a campaign
speech in court he anticipates losing a
lot of money and he wants to kind of set
the stakes high in terms of the
political debate to say how unfair it
all is indeed Trump has played the
victim throughout the trial launching
repeated attacks on the Attorney General
the court clerk and the judge he's a
trump haer and we have to do something
about this is a runaway judge Thursday
morning police were called to the home
of Justice engeron for a reported bomb
threat it was a hoax Trump has
repeatedly been sanctioned for violating
a gag
order for the Real Estate Mogul this
case is personal a final decision will
be made by the judge before the end of
the month and could strike at the heart
of Trump's Persona as king of a real
estate
Empire Jackson Trump also faces a
political fight on Monday as the Iowa
caucuses take place how has the
presidential race changed now that his
top critic Chris Christie has dropped
out well NE to Chris Christie has left
the race and hasn't endorsed anyone yet
and that sets up Monday's Iowa caucuses
as something of a showdown between Trump
Nikki Haley and Ronda santis Trump
maintains a massive lead it's really now
a question of who comes in second in
Iowa and if anyone can get close to
Trump in New Hampshire the following
week Christy's departure increases the
odds however slim they are of someone
now closing in on Trump's massive Le
me to thanks Jackson the US Federal
Aviation Administration is launching a
formal investigation into Boeing the FAA
says the probe will focus on Boeing's
quality control and whether its products
were in a condition for safe operation
last Friday a door plug blew out of an
ataska Airlines plane shortly after
takeoff forcing an emergency landing
Boeing CEO says the company plans to
fully cooperate with the
investigation the covid-19 test kids
Ottawa spent billions of dollars on are
under scrutiny coming up the prime
minister's office responds to a global
news
[Music]
investigation a year-long investigation
by global news is Raising more questions
about the federal government's approval
of a widely used co9 test kit Global
News found that Health Canada ignored
multiple warning signs about btnx the
company supplying the test based just
outside of Toronto documents show btnx
deleted dozens of samples from a study
it submitted to health Canada in October
of 2020 a move that inflated the test
reported ability to detect the virus
btnx has admitted that it removed sample
saying it made changes to quote Focus
the data on the intended use of the
product in a statement the prime
minister's office said these rapid tests
work well and have been successfully
used by millions of Canadians to fight
Co 19 describing Health Canada's
decision-making as independent the
department told global news last month
that it won't reexamine BTN X's license
to sell the
test still ahead how taiwan's
presidential election could be affected
by China's looming
[Music]
presence Taiwan is is getting ready for
its presidential election this Saturday
and much is at stake as China ramps up
its intimidation tactics taiwan's
governing party is adamant on
maintaining Independence while its main
political opposition is hoping to ease
relations with Beijing if they're
elected Jeff simple looks at the
politics at play in the final hours of
taiwan's election campaign China put on
a show of
strength military exercises just north
of the self-governing
island China also launched a rocket
through taiwan's airspace prompting the
government to issue an alert about a
possible incoming strike in between
Taiwan and
China The False Alarm briefly
interrupted taiwan's foreign minister as
he was incidentally discussing the
threat from China so all these kinds of
tactics continue to remind the people
here in Taiwan that there's a danger of
war in between Taiwan and China the
Chinese government has vowed to take
control of Taiwan by force if necessary
and in this election Beijing wants
change at the
top the Democratic Progressive Party is
seeking an unprecedented third term
after 8 years in power the dppp rejects
the Chinese Communist party and wants
greater Independence and relations with
the West its main opposition the kmt
favors closer ties with China opinion
polls suggest the race is close close so
this election is so important right now
these Taiwanese Canadians say the choice
is Stark do you want to choose the uh
Freedom uh democracy or authoritarian
hll show the vast majority of Taiwanese
want democracy and oppose joining China
support for the opposition kmt party has
less to do with its pro-china policies
and more with the cost of living Rising
inequality Rising housing costs and in
inflation this campaign has seen all
three leading candidates Embrace
taiwan's so-called status quo the
delicate balance of protecting its
democracy while avoiding a conflict with
China the question is how do we go about
it how can we continue to maintain our
way of life we seen what happened to
Hong Kong and a lot of people really
don't want to be in that
position China's president has
reportedly ordered his military to be
ready to invade Taiwan by
2027 whoever becomes taiwan's next
president will have that date on their
calendar Jeff simple Global News
Toronto and tomorrow Jeff looks at the
misinformation campaigns plaguing
taiwan's pivotal election including the
weaponization of artificial
intelligence picking up pickle ball next
a Canadian tennis Titan starts fresh on
a new
[Music]
court
they may look similar but skills on the
tennis court don't necessarily translate
to success on the pickle ball court
Canadian tennis star Eugene bushard has
kicked off her pickle ball career as
Mike Armstrong explains that's left Room
to Grow much like the sport itself
here's the deal folks she wants to get
good at this Genie busha went into her
first pickle ball competition she says
with very low expectations point and
nervous return it took her a while to
settle in but she didn't look out of
place that's a nice rip from even if to
her it felt that way like I've played
tennis for 25 years now and so my brain
is like wired for
tennis well the rewiring has begun the
29-year-old shocked the tennis world
last fall when she announced she was
joining the professional pickle ball
Association the PPA already called the
fastest growing sport in North America
the professional League wanted a player
with a profile how much she's being paid
hasn't been released but the transition
for tennis players she says isn't easy
yeah you know it's like it's not like
automatic we're playing against people
who have been training for pickle ball
for years and so they know the ins and
outs of their now busha is one of the
most successful Canadian tennis players
in history she exploded onto the scene
in 2014 with arguably the best year any
Canadian has ever had she made the
semi-finals of of uh the French Open the
semi-finals of the Australian Open and
the finals of Wimbledon so she made it
to at least the final four or better of
the first three majors in the year Char
you said it there was at her Peak buw
was ranked fifth in the world now she
never came close to regaining her top
form but tennis observers say it was
injuries not a lack of effort she still
works her butt off I mean I've seen her
in in tournaments where she's been
bounced early and she sticks around and
she's still hidden the practice courts
and she is working hard and I think
that's a side that the tennis fans and
people that are quick to criticize her
they don't see the works that she's
putting in 74 B says she's Amazed by how
quickly pickle ball is growing and that
she wants to help that said she still
plans to play tennis this year and
admits she does find it sad she drives
by a tennis court that's being converted
to pickle ball Mike Armstrong Global
News
Montreal and that is global national for
this Thursday tonight's here Canada is
Smithers BC where this young viewer
skated on a nearby frozen lake with
fresh snow what a view thanks so much
for watching far Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a great
[Music]
night